Levies,
cough before who said that?
Her cooking in the process by which,
you know,
nature is stress home into culture and
the European civilization,
you know,
tetany you can go back and anything can
be filtered through the food itself.
I mean,
after apology,
history,
sociology,
even politic,
you know,
I mean you have political decision,
uh,
like uh,
the,
the taxal Gabrielle in France in the
17th century for that tax on salt,
those are political decision who decide
where the food goes or other food is
going to be consumed or the embargo of
color in the 70s.
Again,
the grant out of Agu,
again,
a certain country of Europe,
this political decision as we see in
Africa,
an hour,
another part of the world will determine
where the food goes,
who die and new style and who die and
you leave,
you know.
So those are,
whether it's political,
religion,
you know,
food can be,
uh,
the Bible is an enormous,
so for,
for food or for,
for a eastery of food if you want,
you know,
so whether it's sociology,
there is no,
no part of social science which cannot
be really filtered through food.
And to a certain extent,
now it become a subject which is more
not only irrelevant but more respected.
I mean,
at Boston University we are offering now
a master of liberal arts with a
concentration in gastronomy.
I mean,
that would have been totally unthinkable
20,
30 years ago.
Even less than that when I came to
America and I work at the Perio
Trashcans,
you're the greatest French restaurant
here and was part of [inaudible] 89 and
[inaudible] 89 where the dishwasher,
the chef,
the cook to everyone,
we're in the same basket.
There was no difference.
And at that point,
you know,
I have to say that after,
uh,
after,
the pavilion year I worked for Howard
Johnson.
I work with a lot of black people,
black.
We understood the still,
that's what I wear the most into the
kitchen.
And now that,
uh,
the cooking had exploded and I'd become
very glamorous and inspired and even
genius,
like,
you know,
uh,
then,
you,
for some reason,
and I think it's a lost for the country,
don't have many black who are into
cooking now a couple,
you know,
but not many,
but many young American chef are in that
business now,
which as I say,
yeah,
and they go,
they would not even a,
that was considered a lou and inspire
type of a job,
which now it's exactly the opposite.
So we have the peregrination of the chef
is quite interesting because something
happened in the same way in the 17th,
18th century in France.
In fact,
there was a book written by [inaudible]
in the first half of the 18th century,
which is called a nouvelle cuisine for
the new French cooking.
So you see the nouvelle cuisine,
which erupted here in the 70s,
what already existing in the,
in the 1870 when it went down and up.
Why that Tan attacks again during,
uh,
during,
at the end of the 19th century,
at the time of the belly pork,
then it went down and up again.
So it's an interesting,
uh,
tried to look at the story of cooking
a great deal of the cooking and
discharging in baby even more so now,
uh,
there is good and there is bad certainly
thing like the food processor,
uh,
Seran wrap and uh,
and uh,
uh,
plastic or a rubber spatula after me.
Great Innovation of the last 30 years.
Uh,
but uh,
besides this,
you know,
we always manipulate food and uh,
our ancestor,
you know,
uh,
didn't have anything to eat and what we
call weak now was actually a wild the
while the weed,
you know,
which through a cross breeding and
challenging and manipulation.
We ended up now with this,
I mean not that long ago,
whenever the child,
you could not eat string bean before
string on one side and the other side,
which I tried to do and I had to do a
couple of,
uh,
you know,
pound or whatever that my mother wanted
me to do.
My brother and I tried to cut the end of
it with a scissor to which of course
those beans were absolutely or needle.
So now there is always been so many
potential to make it a better,
uh,
without the string or to make the animal
fatter or not as fat or more tender or
this and that.
So those manipulation of existing all
the time now bio engineered food,
it's something else.
You know,
[inaudible] we get into other area which
asked to be control.
I am not by a definition oposed to
anything because I think that to feed
the world,
we need that type of improvement,
but it has to be extremely controlled,
you know?
But without any question,
if you can do an egg,
which tastes like an egg for me are good
and an egg and it has half of the amount
of cholesterol,
why not?
You know,
it's,
you can have a tomato,
uh,
that because of so many progression
doesn't need to be sprayed with an
insecticide and pesticide or leasing
being resistant to this.
Why not that?
Maybe a plus.
But as I say,
you have to do it with circumspection.
You've really have to control it.